- I'm Ahmed Ali Akbar,
and I host the See Something,
Say Something podcast
at Buzzfeed News.
I'm here with my sister Zainab.
- Hi!
- [Ahmed] And we're gonna be making
our mom's Eid lamb biryani.
Islam is an Abrahamic religion,
and Eid Ul Adha celebrates
Abraham's sacrifice
of the lamb and his son,
and so, during that holiday,
Muslims basically take the
meat of a butchered animal
and donate it to charity,
and share food with family and
friends and your neighbors.
- [Zainab] The biryani, to me,
feels like turkey on Thanksgiving.
When we eat at our house on Thanksgiving,
we'd always have a turkey,
but also a biryani,
and like you were saying, every
family has their own recipe.
There are people who have
like, their special tricks,
and they swear like,
their version is like,
the best version.
And like, definitely,
people won't ever tell you
their full recipe, or like,
they'll leave out their secret ingredient
that makes it their special biryani.
But, it comes out on special
occasions, like the turkey.
- [Ahmed] So, when I celebrate Eid,
I usually send some money to like, a farm
to donate some meat to a family in need.
It can take different forms.
Some people do a cow,
some people do a goat.
Some people do a lamb.
But, the ultimate thing
is to share meat with
people who need it, and the
people who are close to you.
- [Zainab] The tradition has
become to slaughter an animal
and to give the meat to friends
and family and to charity,
but the real kernel of truth
or importance to that vision
is to feed those in need.
So, usually, every year,
I donate to a place like
City Harvest or something
so that hungry New Yorkers can eat.
Eid Ul Adha not only celebrates
that Abrahamic story,
but also celebrates the end of Haj.
It's on the 10th day of Dhul Hijja,
which is a month in the Islamic calendar,
and the people who are
doing the pilgrimage,
it's the last day of the pilgrimage,
and it's the day they celebrate
having completed the pilgrimage.
- [Ahmed] It's a very happy holiday.
People come together to share food,
celebrate all around the world.
In Pakistani communities
in America and back home,
you're gonna be seeing
people eat a lot of biryani
and lamb and goat,
so when we celebrate Eid, we wake up
and go to the mosque in the morning,
meet our community, people
from all around the world,
and then we go to parties, usually,
where people are usually serving
meat to a bunch of guests.
When we host a party,
we usually serve, like,
three to five types of meat
that are like, really complicated
and complex and delicious,
and biryani's usually the center of that.
There's like, as many
biryanis as there are people
in India,
- Oh yeah.
- Pakistan, and Bangladesh--
- Yeah.
- [Ahmed] And the sub-continent,
and there's so many ways to make it.
Our mother passed away about
a decade ago almost, now.
She was a very good cook,
and we have some of her
recipes in our head,
but biryani was something
that was so special and rare
that I don't think I at least knew it,
so I was really excited when
I found it in this recipe book
that her and a bunch of
other Pakistani doctors
had put together.
Actually, the recipe we're
making is not exactly like
the one that I remember
because she never shared her secrets.
- [Zainab] She never told anyone
the full recipe,
(Ahmed laughs)
ever.
- [Ahmed] Biryani is definitely
something that I associate
as a party food.
When guests are visiting our house,
that's when my mom would make it.
- [Zainab] Yeah, it's a way to celebrate.
We put so much energy and time
into all the different steps
and the layers of flavor, and that's like,
another way of showing your
family and your friends
how much you love them
and care about them.
(upbeat music)
- Mmm.
- Oh my god.
- So good.
♪ Oh yes ♪
(upbeat music)